まああの初めの講義でも申し上げた通りに
あのいくらか気をつけて聞いていただかないと
なんかわからなくなる可能性はあるんです
それからこの この一つの考え方ですから
このつなげてまた聞かないと
まあ途中で切れちゃったら
またもう全部切れてしまうという恐れもあるんです
まあそういうふうなことをできるだけあの私の方であの気をつけますけど
あのまあ一つ抜けても何か理解できるようにとかね
まあ気はしますけど まあそういうふうに私の方で気をつけると
まあなかなか話は進まなくなるんです
厳密に講義の形でさっさとやると
まあそんなに時間かからなく早くできるんです
二 三ヶ月間でこのテキストを終了することはできますけど
その場合はあの 前言ったような問題が現れてきます
きちんと聞いて すぐその場で理解しないと難しくなるんです
じゃあこの前 正義体と世俗体という 2つの概念を紹介いたしました
で パーリ語でサンムティサッチャ
パラマットサッチャという
まあそこら辺でこの前の講義を終わりました
サンムティサッチャというのは
まあ世俗体 パラマットサッチャっていうのは第一義と書いて
まあ正義体ですね で これちょっとした
また繰り返し説明なんですけど
まあ世の中でどんな人々も
どんな生命でも 人々だけではないんです
大体仏教で考えているのは
全ての生命 いつでも生命として見ているんですね
普通に我々が勉強する時は人間中心に勉強してますけど
当然仏教の話も人間中心ですけど
やっぱり真理を語る場合は
この生命と生命を土台にして考えているんです
ですから このどんな生命であろうか
この認識して正しいと自分で思うものは
全てが世俗体になるんですね
我々人間として いろんなものは
これは真理だ これは真理だと知っている世界がありまして
他の生命も自分たちが知っている世界はそれなりの真理だと知ってるんですね
例えば我々は三次元の世界で生きているんだから
三次元の世界しか知りませんし
他の四次元とか何か次元があるかどうか全然わからないし
まあおそらくないだろうとは思ってるし
それは我々にとっては真理であるし
で 四次元の生命がいるならば
その人々にはやっぱり四次元の世界が存在していて
三次元の世界っていうのは生きていられるんですから
そんな世界にという風に
もう生きていられる環境じゃないと思ってるかもしれません
それはその人々に対しては真理であって
ですから この一応ある
ある立場である側面で物事を見ると
真理だと 本当のものだと考える全てのことをサンムティサッチャ
あるいは世俗体として見ているんですね
まあサッチャ 真理という言葉を使ってはいるんだから否定しているわけじゃないんです
だからといってそれは絶対的な真理にはならないんですね
で まあわかりやすく言えば
ご飯はおいしいということは
我々ご飯を食べる人間にとっては真理であって
ご飯は食べない人々にとっては別にそれは真理にはならなくなっちゃうんですね
それから全く例えば野生の動物なんかはご飯を食べることはしませんし
その動物にすれば一番美味しい食べ物は何ですかと聞いたら
聞いたら違う答えが出てくるんですね
だから例えば ライオンに聞いて聞けばね
一番美味しい食べ物は何ですかと
まあそれなりの何かこういう餌は一番美味しいと言うかもしれませんし
ハエに聞いたらやっぱりもっと腐った方が一番美味しいと言うかもしれませんし
ライオンの方がやっぱり殺したすぐその場のその時血が出ている時
食べた方が一番美味しいと言うだろうと
もう人間の勝手に推測しますけど
もう まあでもそのその次元で
その中で彼は自分では真理を語っていると思ってるんですし
我々も人間の次元で真理を語っていると思ってるんですね
ですから そこは世俗体であると
いわゆる第一義の第一義体ではないんだとと言ってるのは
また仏教なんですね なんで世俗体と分けたかというと
世俗体っていうのは変化するという
特色を持ってるんですね
そこからこの我々は生起体の世界に入るんです
で 接触体というのはある条件の中で
その現象ですね この現象は真理でありますけど
その条件ちょっと変えるとそれは変わってしまうんですね
でもう一つ例を出すならば
こちらはチョーク1本あるんですね
これを見ると 誰でもこれはまあ黒板で描くチョーク1本だと思うし
でもチョークというものは人間聞けば本当にありますかとまあありますよと言うんだけど
でもそれはちょっと こう指ででも削るとチョークが違うものになっちゃうんですね
粉になってしまうんですね
粉になったところで 我々はただなんとか白い粉と呼んでやって
チョークとは言わないんですね
チョークの場合はもう書くという仕事がありますけど
粉になったらそういう仕事はできなくなって
我々から見れば まあただゴミで汚れているということになってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば本が世の中にありますか？と聞けば
当然本というものはあるんですね
でもでも 本を 1冊をどんどんバラしてみると
違うものになっていっちゃうんですね
違う言葉でそれを我々は認識するんですね
本をバラしたところで
我々に紙というものは出てくるんですね
その時は本はどこに行ったんですか？と聞きたくなっちゃうんですね
それで紙をさらにさらに分解してみると
違うものがどんどん出てくるんですね
ですから この実体はないという言葉に入ってほしいんですね
例えば本といっても 本たる実体はないんだと
なぜならば その本をバラしてみたら紙になるんであって
この紙のどんな紙が本として活動してくれたかとかね
でもないんですね 消えてしまうんですね
でも我々は本と言っちゃったら何か認識して
あ 本はありますと 本というものは存在するんだと思って実体的にとるんですが
その本自体をバラしてみると
本は消えちゃう 消えていったい本はどこにあったかという疑問が生まれてくるんですね
そういうふうにものをちょっと条件変えてみると
前もっと先あったと思っていたものは次に消えてしまうんですね
そこを理解してほしいと
仏教で言ったら実体はないということですね
とにかく言っているのは
だから深く考えなくても
それぐらいのことは理解できるのではないかと
ですから 私たちは見ている世界で
で 何でもいいんです で
例えばご飯を作ってちゃんと置いておくと
そうすると あ 美味しいご飯だと
それはちょっとスプーンでも何でもいいんだけど
むちゃくちゃちょっとあちこちもうもうごちゃ混ぜにしたりとかね
あるいは同じご飯をビニール袋か何とかポイと入れておくとかね
その場合は あ 美味しいご飯ですというあの概念が消えていって
生ゴミですということになっちゃうんですね
そこで あ これは美味しいご飯ですという場合は
我々は実体でとってるんですね
あ これは美味しいご飯です
それには食べたらすごく美味しいんですとかね
そう いろんな感情が生まれてくるんですね
そのご飯はほんのちょっと変化させただけで生ゴミになるんですね
そうすると我々は違う感情を持つんですね
生ゴミだ 処分しなくちゃいけないんだ
腐った ちょっと時間経っちゃったら腐って臭いますよとかね
夏だったらその日でやっぱり片付けなくちゃいけないとかね
違う概念が生まれてくるんですね
そこで我々は感情も変わっていっちゃうんですね
で 仏教でいうのは だからあなた方は何をとらわれ
何にとらわれているんですかと
結局そういう現象にとらわれているんですね
すべてのものはそういう
私の子供だ 私の家だ 私の財産だ
私の若さだとかね 私の美しさ
私の体力とか 私は大変名誉とかね
そういうものに我々はとらわれているんだけど
それ一つ一つちょっとしたことで変化するものであると
だから何にとらわれているんですかと
我々は現象から現象へ物事を変えていくんだけど
現象を変えるととらわれている感情を捨てるんではなくて
違う感情を作って そこでまた苦しくないものを作っちゃうんですね
例えば 美味しいご飯に対してある感情を持って
煩悩を持って それは生ゴミになったら違う感情
違う煩悩を持って どっちにしたって苦しみなんですね
美味しいご飯見てる ああ
美味しいな 食べたいなと欲が出てきて
やっぱり貪り食べちゃったらもう体重が増えるんではないかとかね
自分がちょっと高血圧だから
これはちょっと食べたらどうですかとか
いろいろ感情が生まれてきて
生ゴミになったところで
そこで困ってるんですね
人間っていうのは 生ゴミになった瞬間でもう生ゴミに対する感情が生まれてきて
そこでまでまた困ったりはするんですね
ですから この例えば何か電気製品買ってくる
もう買う前の感情と あれはすごくいいものだとかね
買いたいなとか思っていて
それで買うと 買って持ってきたらまた違う感情が生まれてくる
あの製品価値がもう消えちゃうんです
一旦買っちゃったら そこでどう使いますか？あーだこうだとか
違うトラブルがあって
でもこれ故障しちゃったら
もし修理できないといったところで
すぐそれはゴミになっちゃうんですね
その場合はゴミに対する違う感情が生まれて
そこでまた混乱 トラブルは人間にあるんですね
ですから この現象はすぐ変えて
変えて変えて変化していきますね
で その一つの現象を見ると実体がないんですね
例えばテレビと言うんですね
テレビがありますと それでテレビに対する我々の感情があるんですね
でもテレビを分解してみると
テレビが消えて他のものになるんですね
そうするとテレビという実体はなかったんですね
なかったんだけど 我々はテレビという実体があるんだというふうなことを考えているんですね
考えてないんだけど なんとなく本能的にそう受け取っているんですね
で この本能的に受け取っているところは
我々は問題として扱っているんですね
やっぱりきちんと見なさいと
そうすると実体はないということはわかるでしょうと
この感覚で 感情で やっぱりテレビはあるんだとかね
もう型の方が一番いいんだとかね
ハイビジョンだったらもっといいんだとかね
そういういろんなものを考えているかもしれません
それは実体で取っているんですね
だから実体で取っているんだから
執着はそこに生まれる
そこで変化したら違うものになるんだから
やっぱり実体はなかったと思った方がいいのに
そう思わないんですね
この変えたものについて
また実体論を映してもらうんですね
すごくバカバカらしいことなんですけど
その世界は世俗態と仏教で言ってるんです
だから すべての人間の知識
我々が生きてる世界 すべては世俗態と
そこで次に考え出すのは
この じゃあ正義態って何ですかと
やっぱり究極的に物事を分解して分解していくと
どこかで止まるんではないかなという
ごく普通な このヨーロッパでも起こりた
起こった この科学的な発想の同じ発想で考えてみたいんですね
例えばテレビだというと
私たちの心の中で何かの認識が生まれる
部品だと思ったら違う認識が生まれる
家だ 建物だというと また何か認識が生まれる
人だ 人間だというと また何か生まれるんだから
何をもって我々は人間だ
家だ 落ちだ 建物だ テレビだ
部品だとかね ゴミだとか言ってるんですかと
なぜ我々の心にそういうふうに変化が起こるんですかと
この心に起こる変化は確実な変化なんですね
その心に確実な変化が起こるのは
確実な何か影響を心に入るんだからではないかと
何も影響なしに心はもう自分勝手に変化するというよりは
いろいろ影響があって
その影響によって変化していくんだから
ですから テレビを見て心に起こる変化と
あの洗面器を見て心に起こる変化っていうのは違いますから
ですから テレビが何か私の心の変化しますから
そこに何かあって 洗面器にそれはなくて
洗面器に何かあって それはテレビにないというふうな
まあ理屈は立てられるんですね
もしどっちでも同じものを持っているならば
テレビ見ても同じ感情で
同じく洗面器見ても楽しくなるはずなんですね
テレビ見たと同じく でもそうはならないんですね
ですから この じゃあ一体全体その究極的に何がありますかと
それはできるだけ変化しない
あの変化しないではなくて
この意味が変えられないものまで
あの 何て言いますか 分析して分析していかなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでこの４つの生起体が出来上がったんですね ４
つの生起体 １はチッタ
これは全部この この前言ったことの繰り返しなんですね
今日はこの４つ もう少々詳しく説明しようと思います
で １番目はチッタというんですね
それは心 日本語で言えば心
で で 問題はここに私がいるということですから
私がここにいるんだから
ここにいろんな現象論が生まれてくるし
人がいるんではないか
ないんではないかとか
いろんな問題が生まれてくるし
だから自分がこの物事を認識する
認識するものは全部現象でもありますし
だからその問題はとにかく自分が認識するんだから
そういう問題が生まれるんだから
まずこの認識する働きだけ取るんですね
例えばテレビを認識する
洗面器を認識する 部屋を認識する
ドアを認識する 人間を我々を認識する
今言ったのは全部目で見て認識するものでだけですけど
例えば声を認識する 耳で聞いてそれを認識する
いろんなものを触って触れて我々認識する
例えば寒い 暖かいとかいうのは体で認識してしているものなんですね
それから頭で考えて 心でいろんなものを考えて
我々は物事を認識する
現象を認識する ですから
とにかく究極的にあるのは認識するという働きなんですね
それはそれ以上分析はできないんです
認識する ただ その機能だけ取ると
それで終わるんですね
例えば目があって 我々はもう数え切れないほどを見てものを見ているかもしれませんだけど
じゃあ人間にどれぐらいのものを見えますかというと答えられ
人間にはやっぱりいろんなもの見えるんだから
虫も見えるし お坊さんも見えるし
普通の人間も見えるし
他のものも見えるし 目を開けたら
ですから 人間に見えるものというふうに勉強しようとすると
何の意味もないバカバカらしいことになっちゃうんですね
ですから そういう方向で見るんじゃなくて
人間には見えるという機能があるんだと言ったら
それで一つで終わっちゃうんですね
人間に見えるという機能があって
それで見えるという認識が起こるんだと
いわゆる視覚という認識が起こるんだと言えば
一つで物事を済んでしまっちゃうんですね
でもそうすると 聴覚とか味覚とかいろいろ認識ができてくるんだから
もうそれもたくさんだから困っていて
やっぱり認識する認識機能
認識という働き それを心というんですね
そうすると世の中でそれは一つしかないんです
だからすごい難しい 我々の世界をいきなり一つに絞られるんです
例えば 前言ったように
犬の世界と人間の世界というのはすごい違う世界なんですね
犬が綺麗だと思うものと人間が綺麗だと思うのは
それは勉強していても全然勉強もできないし
別に役に立つということにならないんですね
例えば綺麗というものは何でしょうかと定義しようと思って
綺麗という概念を普遍的な真理として私は語りますよと思った人が
ある全ての人間が何が綺麗だと言ってるんですかと全部データを集めて
それから犬が何が綺麗だと言ってるんだと
そのデータを集めて 猫が何が綺麗だと思ってるんですかと
そういうデータを集めて
それから何かを結論を出さなくちゃいけない
出せっこはないものなんですね
決して答えが出てこないんですね
ですから 科学の世界はそういうやり方でやってますけど
で 仏教では大体かえって逆に
まず認識する機能を考えちゃうんですね
そこで認識する機能があるんだと言ったら
犬にも認識する機能があるんですね
猫にも物事を認識する機能があるんですね
それからミミズも同じくそういうものあるんですね
それからアメーバにしたっても
環境はちゃんと認識しているんですね
環境のことを全く知らなきゃ
アメーバさえ生きていられませんね
じゃあウイルスはどうですかと
ウイルスもきちんと半分の半分生命なんですけど
科学的に言えば でも我々より賢く環境を認識しているんですね
自分に生きていられる環境はどういう環境かと
悪い環境で自分がどうやって存続しますかとか
人間より賢いんですね
ですから その認識する機能があるんだと言っちゃったら
もう我々はウイルスのことも言ったことになるし
人間のことも言ったことになるし
例えば人間全く知らない超次元的な神々
梵天とかね そういう人々のことも言ったことになっちゃうんですね
ですから 正義体第1番目は心ですよと言ったら
それはすべての生命に対する変化しない唯一の真理になってしまっちゃうんですね
すべての生命に生命であるならば
認識する機能 認識する働きがありますよと
ですから 心の定義は何ですかというと
認識する機能を心というというふうな定義なんですね
これは心の定義なんですね
アーランマナ・ヴィジャーナナ・ラッカナン・チッタン
それはローマ字で見るとすごい長い文章に見えますし
もうなかなか覚えにくいかもしれませんだけど
アーランマナっていうのは対象と普通に言っている
いわゆる環境ですね 外の世界ですね
環境 外の世界 それは自分の体も入ってるんです
だから対象と訳した方がいいんです
ヴィジャーナっていうのは知ること
知る 知ってることですか
知ること あるいは認識することですね
対象を認識する 特色 ラッカーナっていうのは特色
本性 本性の方がもっと意味があるんです
専門用語ですけど 本性というのは仏教で使っている
その本性は心ですと なんか聞くとすごい難しく聞こえますけど
すごく簡単なものなんです
いわゆるこの こういうことですね
アビダンマの狙いは 特に仏教の狙いは
私たちはこの 例えば地理学やら音楽やら科学やら
いろんなことを勉強するとすごいワクワクして
もう大変なものを得たような気持ちになっちゃうんですね
どんどん自分の高慢やら自分がこれ知ってるんだ
あれ知ってるんだとか
これで食べていけているんだとかね
ありとあらゆる煩悩が生まれちゃうんですね
それからやりきれない世界生まれてくるんですね
どんどん勉強すればするほど苦しみが増やしちゃうんですね
そこで 80歳になっても 90歳になっても
またいっぱい勉強しなくちゃいけないことが残ってるんだから
あっちこっち走り回って
いろいろなものを勉強して勉強して
積み込んで積み込んでいっちゃうんですね
それで普通の勉強っていうのは
欲を増やす 苦しみを増やす
人間の生きる重さがどんどん増やしちゃうんですね
たとえお茶入れるとなんとかちょっとお湯かけてお茶入れちゃえばそれで飲めますけど
それについてとことん勉強したら
簡単にお茶は入れられなくなっちゃうんですね
すごい難しい仕事になってしまっちゃうんですね
それにプロになったら
本人はお茶を淹れることも大変クッソい仕事になって
我々いい加減にサッととっと飲んじゃったらまたかえって怒られるんですね
そうじゃなくて こういう風に
こういう風に飲みなさいと
なぜならば 本人にはそれぐらい膨大な知識があるんだから
それで飲む人ももう困らせるということはよくあるんじゃないんですか
例えば若者の音楽っていうのは
ただ聞けばいいんですね
むちゃくちゃ体を動かして
もう何も中身も何もないんですね
雑音だけで 音だけで それでまあすごい品格の高い
もういろいろクラシック音楽とか何とかになっちゃったら
そういうわけにはいきませんね
聞く人もえらい修行しながら聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
ちょっとも音を立てないで
結局なんか変ではないかと
もし音楽のレベルが高くなれば高くなるほど
軽く簡単に楽しめるはずなんですけど
逆になってるんですね
その現象は音楽だけではなくて
すべての人間の知識にあることなんです
子供にとっては幼稚園なんかに行ってなんとか学ぶことはえらい楽しい
なんですけど でもどんどんそれは本当にとことん追求して勉強するという
そこに地獄の苦しみが付いているんですね
それは世の中の知識の世界
仏教の知識の世界っていうのは全く逆効果なんです
逆の働きなんですね 勉強すればするほど軽くなって
まあ別に知らなくたっていいんじゃないかという
ところに持っていくんですね
それはこの心の働きだけ見た時のその機能が見えると思います
例えば生命のことを勉強しようと思ったら
みんな気持ちよく ああ
いいですねと そうすると一人が虫の研究で終わっちゃうし
もう一人が哺乳類の研究でもあるワンスピーシース
ある一種の勉強で全部終わっちゃうし
じゃあ人間の体を勉強してほしいって言っても
やっぱり人間の体の一部だけの勉強で人の人生終わってしまっちゃうし
で それを苦しみの世界になってきて
仏教になるとそうじゃなくて
すべての生命 我々知ってる生命も知らない生命も全部まとめて生命というのはいろんなものを認識するんだから
そうでないと生命とは言えないんだから
ですから この認識する機能
その角度で見ると一つしかない
それであのものすごい大変な知識の世界はすぐ一つにまとめてしまっちゃう
じゃあそれで認識機能はどう働きますかと勉強しちゃえば
すべての生命のことをわかったことになってしまっちゃうんですね
簡単に 全部ある角度で把握したことになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから この勉強の場合は
心は軽らかになる ものすごく気持ちよくなって
煩悩いっぱい積み込むというよりは
何か落ち着いてしまっちゃう
まあなんだ まあそんなもんですかと
例えば余計な話かもしれませんだけど
この超次元現象に興味ある人々は結構いるんですね
いろいろ何て言いますか
あれは このいろんなこの亡くなった人々からコンタクト取ったりしたりとか
あるいはチャネリングですか
チャネラーとか会って何々さんこれから呼びますよとかね
アメリカのケネディ大統領呼びますよとかね
なんとか言って みんなでいろいろやったりとかね
で それで それでじゃあ生命のことわかりますか
そういう人々は たとえ
たとえ あるチャネラーが本当に亡くなったケネディ大統領の霊を呼んで
何か情報を取ったと それもきちんと正しい情報だと決めても
じゃあそれをもってその人は存在のことをわかったんですかね
全然わからない それで説明つきますかね
どうやって人が亡くなって
どういう次元でどういう風な生命生きれるんですかとか
わからない それでもすごい苦しみが生まれるだけなんですね
それだと よりたくさんの霊を呼べるチャネラーが出てきたら
そこで競争が生まれてきちゃうし
その入ってくる情報によってまた文政が混乱してしまいちゃうし
ですから この この生命体制もそういうふうにこの生き方
やり方でやると終わりがないんですね
そこですごい簡単に自分の体を見ると
自分がここにいるという実感が
自分が環境を認識している
それは究極的な意味ですと
それ以上分析することはできない
ですから 第一次態の あるいは小儀態の一番目は心
それは認識するという機能のみ
その認識する機能 純粋にそれだけなんです
次に問題が生まれる 我々は認識するだけでは終わりません
例えば ここにご飯があって
私はそれを目で見て 鼻で感じて
認識する そこで犬が来て
それ犬にも見える次元だから
それ犬が認識する その点では同じなんですね
でも 犬が認識してどんな感情生まれるか
私はそれを認識認識してどんな感情生まれるかというと
そこに差があるんですね
それは何か差があるんですね
じゃあその差どうやって説明しますかと
とまた問題が生まれてくる
そこで判断でいっちゃえばただの妄想の世界なんです
美味しいご飯ですよというのは判断ですね
そうすると それは私にとって美味しいんだけど
他の人にとって 他の生にとって美味しいということになりませんだから
美味しいという判断には至りませんだから
ですから 判断に行かないで
すごく気をつけて認識する
そこで感情をいろいろ生まれる
その感情のみ それだけ取って
また普遍的な真理を作っちゃうんです
それはチータ・シッカと言われるんですね
あのパーリ語 日本語の言葉はあの
あまり正しい言葉ないんだけどね
まあ心所とか書くんだけどね
で 私たちは考えて 他の何か言葉考えてもいいんだけど
あのまあこれから説明いたしますので
その説明からもっと違う
もっと意味が通じる言葉ないかなと
で これはこの厳密にこの原語
元の言葉を分解して分析して漢字を当てられているぐらいなんですね
いわゆる厳密な翻訳なんですね
字義通りの 特に仏教経典
漢訳仏典というのは この
あのサンスクリット語
パーリ語の言葉はそのままもう文字を文字
向こうの言葉の代わりに漢字を入れ込むというぐらいのことで
ですから まあ原文 元の言葉を知っている人にとっては分かりますけどね
漢字だけ知っている人には意味がわからない
だいたいこの これはこの文法用語としてね
漢文では使っている言葉でもあって
場所を示すところでもありまして
だからどっちの意味で取ればいいかと
漢字だけ知っている人たちですと
よくわかりにくいんですね
心所といえば まあとにかく
まあこれから説明いたします
そこで我々はものを認識する
認識すると何か感情が生まれる
その感情の中でちょっと普遍的なものはないかなと探してみましょう
例えばご飯を見て ああ
美味しいんだというのは
そんなに普遍的なものじゃないんです
でも見つかるものあるんですね
例えば 私はご飯を見て美味しいという感覚は生まれる
いわゆる気持ちいいとか
それで犬が生肉を見たところで
ああ 同じ私と似ている感覚がそこに生まれる
で 人間だったらもう人間の相手を見たら
ああ 綺麗な人やと思って
ある感情を作る で 猿は自分のオス猿はもう同じメス猿を見たら
ああ綺麗 美人だなと同じ感情が生まれる
そこで似ているんですね
別にメス猿はすごいべっぴんさんということではなくて
人間を男性から見れば女性の方がすごい美しい美人だよという
そういう それは真理というそういうことじゃなくて
何か見たところで何か似てる
感情生まれてるんではないかと
そこだけ取るんですね
似てるんだと だから この腐ってる葉っぱやら土
土になりかけてる葉っぱなんか食べてるミミズも
それは餌として食べてるんだから
そのものに生まれる感情と
美味しいご飯を食べてる私たちに生まれる感情は
感情から見ると同じなんですね
そこで 嫌な騒音やら嫌なもうもうもうすごい寒いところか
すごい暑いところか ひどい臭いがするところとか
もうそういうところで我々いるとものすごく居心地居心地が悪くて
嫌な感じがするんですね
それでミミズを取ってきて
まあちょっと道路の上に置いておく
あるいは一応土の中から掘って上に置いておく
そうするとミミズにとってはものすごい嫌な感情なんですね
光が当たってるんだから
空気が触れてるんだから
そうするとぐにゃぐにゃと自分の体いろいろこの
あ この環境嫌だ 早く土の中に行かな
戻らなくちゃいけないという
その環境から逃げよという
身を守るという感情が生まれるんですね
そこで私たちがいるところで
ものすごい騒音が入るわ
ひどい臭いが入るわとか
あるいはもう排気ガス
空気が汚れてるわとかいう状態でも
すごい体は気持ち悪くて
なんかどこか他のいいところないかとかね
その環境から逃げようという感情が生まれるんでしょう
その点ではミミズも人間も同じですね
そういうものは心所ということで扱ってるんですね
そこで じゃあ次に問題が生まれる
認識するだけだったら一つなんですね
でも感情といえば一つじゃないんですね
美味しいご飯見たところで生まれる感情と
もうご飯食べた人がそれをもう戻しちゃったと
それ戻したものを見て生まれる感情っていうのは全く同じですよということは
ちょっと言いづらいんですね
ですから 感情の場合は一つではないということは明確なんですね
じゃあそれはどれぐらいやりますかというと
我々思うほどたくさんないんです
我々の認識から見れば
好きという感情と あ 嫌だ嫌いだという感情っていうのは
だいたいわかって だいたい人間に言えばそれぐらいなんですね
あるいは まあ別にまあつまらないと
どうでもいいと それぐらい感情はよくわかってるんですね
それから たまに嫌いだけではなくて
すごくムカッとして怒ると
なんか感情の険しさ感じちゃうんですね
それからたまに我々嫉妬とかね
そういうものもよく認識できるんですね
嫉妬があるんだと 嫉妬
憎しみとかね そういうふうな
感情の差がわかりますね
そんなにたくさんないんです
例えば嫉妬だったら動物にもあるし
人間にもあるし それは何か見て嫉妬する
何か聞いて嫉妬する そんなもんだから
ですから この感情の方が我々は五十二ありますと
一応仏教では五十二種類のものを考えているんですね
それでこの五十二を勉強してしまえば
もう別に勉強するものは何も残らない
残らないんですね それでもう一つ
もうちょっとさらに説明はあります
で 私たちが私に心があるというんですね
心があるということを環境は知ることなんですね
それで我々には心はその場でその場で変わるんです
瞬間瞬間心が変わってしまっちゃう
心という大雑把な言葉で感情をまとめて心というんですね
普通に喋る場合は厳密ではなくて
そこでこの部屋に入った瞬間の心と
ちょっと五分間座っていたところの心と
あるいは今日の講義が始まる前に瞑想なんかしていたところと
講義が始まったところの心とか
講義が進んでいくと生まれる心とかね
それぞれそれぞれ全部変わって変わっていくんですね
たまに同じ人間が瞬間瞬間的に全く別人になってしまっちゃうんですね
それは我々は認めないだけで
本当はいつでも我々は別人になっちゃうんですね
ここでいる間は別人で
ここから離れたらまた違う人間で
電車に乗ったらまた別人で
家に戻ったらまた別人で
仕事に戻ったらまた違う人間で
ものすごく違う人間になっちゃうんですね
でも我々はそれを認めたくない
俺は俺だと 何やったって
もう決まる なんか証拠ないのに決まってるんですね
それは置いておいて やっぱりまあ体が
体も変わるんだからね
ここで座ってて疲れたなと思っても
授業終わって外に出ちゃったら別に疲れも何もないし
あるいは喫茶店なんかに行っちゃったら
また違う体の感じも違うし
心も違うし 違う人間になるんですね
瞬間瞬間 それでこの なんで認識することだけたった唯一の